so the topic that we're going to talk
about today at trends in information
security thank you very much for having
me today this is Mike information a
little bit i know i was just introduced
but for those who did not Peter will
give you a quick background I'm in the
information security space for quite
some time consulted in the space
invented various products currently on
the CEO of a company that just put out
its first product which is an engine
that wants people if they're making
inappropriate social media post it to be
the bee product so that businesses don't
get harmed by employees we can data in
the life I write a column as I mentioned
before it's currently carried by ink
previously by syndicated to several
other venues and my pieces appear in
various other areas and including you'll
find some interesting pieces that ever
not a simpler in website one thing I
should begin with it is holiday season
simply learning which is the firm that
sponsor today's webinar has agreed to
give participants half off any course
that they register from after this
webinar on security this is highly
unusual typically a fine coupons ten
twenty percent cap off is a really nice
holiday gift so if you're looking at
taking a formal course if you're looking
to do see ISPs certification of the life
this may be a good time so write down
this code and take a look at the website
afterwards and i apologize i have a
little cold so hopefully i'm still clear
we're going to look at trends in
information security and by trends I
don't mean what the latest fad so I mean
how we got to where we are and where
we're going different big picture
elements and future webinars and this
will be a series of webinars which may
drill down more in detail in some of the
things but we're also going to look at
excuse me how human ever and human
weaknesses are contributing to things
that shouldn't be problems anymore
remaining big problems than the light so
if we want to understand cyber security
and cyber attacks and trends related to
these we need to understand cyber
attacks in general and the first
question is you know why are people
doing them and who is doing so when we
talk about why there's an old saying in
the United States why does somebody
robbed a bank because that's where the
money is and it's true in the cyber
world as well people who are attacking
sites are doing so because there's a
reason to go to those sites either it's
money or its data or some other reason
but there's some reason that they're
doing it in order to achieve a goal that
they have with typically less risk than
it would have if they did it in the
physical world robbing a bank going into
the bank where the gun is typically a
lot more risky for people that's trying
to steal money online for example who is
doing this and this is a very important
point when it comes to trends and this
impacts many other trends you can see
the picture from the movie wargames in
the top right that's the early 1980s in
those days it was kids playing around
the pre commercialization of the
internet with kids trying to prove their
technical skills or are curious and the
life over time we have hacktivists
defacing websites we have criminals
starting to enter the world of cyber or
reducing its individuals or small groups
but today we've graduated and we have
organized crime doing this we have
nation-states doing this we have
terrorist groups doing this so we're
talking about a whole different set of
actors and that has a tremendous impact
all information security in both some of
the fence and in all kinds of
perspective the parties who are doing
the worst bridges today because the
parties that are causing the biggest
waves for businesses and individuals to
let the fence standpoint
are not looking to demonstrate their
technical knowledge they're looking to
achieve aims and in many cases
deniability is important they want to
achieve those names with nobody knowing
that they're the ones who did it very
different than the early happy also as a
result of this attacks may not be
totally technological in nature somebody
may social engineer and employee with a
phone call and then use information that
they gained from that to do something
technological someone may try to
physically enter a building and then
exploit something we're talking about a
blend of technologies because you're
dealing with much more sophisticated
parties I should say a blend of attack
mechanisms as technology has advanced
we've also seen another change which is
today you know your firewall in your
organization is not the first or second
generation of firewall we've had you
know dozens of generations of technology
in the defense perspective but we're
still a human version one guy and so
while you still will see technological
exploits utilized very very often we're
trying to we're seeing that the human is
the first step into the organization
excuse me and in fact because
technologies are better many times when
breaches are going to involve
technological stuff they involve
multiple what we call zero-day exploit
so exploits where the vulnerability was
not known to the public at the time that
it was exploited in which no patch or no
fix was available another important
point to realize and this is something
that I've been speaking about for many
years but it's becoming more and more of
a clear concept that I definitely a
trend the trend is towards trying to
steal data in many cases more than
trying to steal money directly and this
is a result of several factors the first
one is that when money disappears from
someone's account they know about it so
if somebody steals a million dollars
from a bank account there's no way to
have the party who had the money stolen
not know about it over a long period of
time I shouldn't say there's no way it's
very very difficult to get the balance
draw on the other hand if so many copies
data from a server that they weren't
supposed to access
the original data remain and so the
party that was breached may not know
that the data was stolen and they never
know that the data was stolen so there's
a lot greater chance of a getting away
with it and be being able to take action
that the victim doesn't know how to know
that they need to defend against the
other thing is that financial
institutions and online shopper large
online venues for shopping online
retailers use all sorts of antifraud
technologies to detect fraudulent
transactions the financial links in the
life which makes it a lot less easy to
get away with these types of crimes than
simply copying data let's look about
some of the newer threats and these are
selling new but they're on the newer end
and they're part of trends that we need
to be aware of so we see the keyword apt
advanced persistent threats a lot and
again at a high level what this refers
to is parties that are advanced so these
are sophisticated parties nation-states
criminal organizations that are
well-funded and they are persistent and
but for system what we mean is that
they're not opportunistic I'm not going
out there if I'm an apt attacker and
saying hey I'm just interested in
stealing credit cards in general and
wherever I can get them I'm going to get
them these people are typically
targeting specific parties for specific
reasons and so you know my goal is to
breach company acts and cause problems
for company access no company action
information not so much my goal is to
get information and these are threats
because these are intent on undoing
something bad so you if someone who
sophisticated wants to do something that
has the capability of doing it and it's
persistent to do it until they achieve
it really examples where the term was
used would be stuck in an operation
Aurora these were major breaches stuff
in Iran operational world was believed
to be trapped in time various distances
but the point is that the actors were
intent on harming specific party of
reaching a specific party for specific
reasons very often these parties are
exploiting multiple mechanisms including
zero of the attacks
and almost always rely on human error
somewhere in the process in offspring of
this concept is that we now have the
ability to I might want to say we don't
need any persons and we as a society
have the abilities that you'll all sort
of sophisticated attacks against both
corporations and individuals these
things to abuse direct someone's life
are stealing of pictures and information
indicating it as we've seen in certain
situations and liquor videos for
industrial espionage so this is
definitely the apt is for coming or has
been and its continuing to be a
significant aspect I mean if you think
about the Sony breach not that long ago
I that was an example of what might
happen from an apt what's interesting is
that we've forgotten major lessons from
the physical world and it's part of
what's caused this problem there's no
such thing as a free lunch so many times
malware that gets using part of some
sophisticated attached is delivered
because someone was downloading
something for free or got an email okay
here's some pictures of something or
free video there's no such thing as free
to somebody's offering something for
free there's a reason for it and
sometimes that's malicious likewise we
have people who are using cloud services
and have no idea whatsoever about the
security of the vendor then the provider
that they're using which again doesn't
make very much sense when you're dealing
with sophisticated technology and of
course we have people communicating with
websites if they know maybe run by
criminal parties because there's
something on the site that they want
either super discounted item or you've
got something that's given away for free
you don't want to be doing this what's
interesting is that even when it comes
to USB drives and plugging the phones
into chargers we see very very little
security being practiced in many
situations you have businesses that will
disable USB ports but you have many
people who will borrow the USB Drive
without thinking about it where we'll
plug their phone into avara charge
without thinking about the fact that
they're now plugging something into
what's usually the communication port of
the device
in the 1980s they used to say don't put
floppy drives into your computer if you
don't know that those guys are saying
you know that this has not been
inconclusive artists but today somehow
that concept seems to have been weakened
maybe because we have such good endpoint
security solutions native our solutions
people were a lot on the technology to
work and that doesn't always happen this
could end up becoming a model also for
biological attacks just like Stuxnet
with a custom piece of thing for example
to affect certain centrifuges that the
Iranians were using and not to do damage
to other systems even though would
propagate through them the tensions
there could be biological weapons to
attack people to certain forms of DNA no
like this is just an existing point
ransomware is a trend that doesn't seem
to be disappearing it's a problem I
should say that doesn't seem to
disappear and it's certainly part of a
twin and we're going to talk about this
an advancement I read somewhere in a
minute but the point is that ransom
areas where somebody gets some elder on
a computer or pretends to ml or computer
that says that if you don't pay them
money they're going to release your file
so delete Summoner files corrupted files
into life in order for this to get
install someone almost always has to
make a mistake and get let them out or
get onto the machine we now for your
friends words data leaking on social
media and obviously I'm in this space so
I ask you this all the time these things
have led to things such as kidnappings
and what we call virtual kidnappings
that's when someone pretends that
kidnapped the relative but the relative
is unable to be reached at the time so
you can't verify that they have a
relative or don't and therefore you may
pay the ransom did a piece on CNBC about
this is actually a big problem many
major cities today you've got
information leaking on social media
that's also leading to spear phishing
attacks okay and obviously classic data
loss prevention sitting at the firewall
or standing the cloud is not going to do
anything if somebody is leaking data on
a social media account on the weekend
from a personal device for mana party
excuse me smart devices we'll talk about
this here and also in relation to
embedded systems smart devices which we
all have on our phones and we've all got
all sorts of smart devices and we may
have purchased
our homes of business these things are
really internet computers that are doing
all sorts of other functions in many
ways with the Internet at me if you're
wearing a 58 or a job on or some sort of
other health tracking device that's got
all sorts of information about you
transmitting it by bluetooth to your
phone and then sinking to a server all
this kind of information is very
valuable to criminals the proliferation
of these devices is obviously leading to
possibilities of stealing the data like
embedded systems but your car today sold
in America is that computers in it in
fact we think of them as cars but we
don't think about them as computers with
wheels and a steering wheel in the life
but this actually has big consequences
because these computers are potentially
hackable and that could be dangerous on
has the van our found to be on cars yet
not yet but we have had hacking going on
so these are things that you know as the
market produces more and more Internet
of Things devices you're going to see a
trend toward security issues there and
that brings us to extreme ransomware
imagine somebody driving a vehicle and
the ransomware doesn't say I'm going to
link you know encrypt your data it says
I'm going to crash your car you don't
pay me that's a very very serious threat
or with a pacemaker someone has a smart
pacemaker and if you know ransomware
says hey you need to pay me or I'm going
to do something to your pacemaker and
it's going to kill you if this science
fiction on a real world well let me
judge for yourself this article is
actually from several years ago ready
about a smart pacemaker that would
transmit information over a network so
doctors to monitoring and of course if
information were corrupted by a hacker
along the way that could lead to bad
things and as we have devices and are
embedded in us physically or in hospital
receive signals over a network is
obviously more risk this is a piece from
this year about a hacker who managed to
stop a vehicle remotely while it was
being driven so this is not science
fiction these are real issues and you
can't buy security software for your car
to that you're relying on the vendor to
get things right but there are issues
and this is just a few months ago so
obviously there's going to be a trend
towards dealing with these security
issues I as time goes on
part of the problem is it's like a lot
of school we don't view in that existed
in as computers we view them as devices
we had cars 20 years ago that had no
computers we just see a car with more
function and that creates all these
kinds of issues the same thing with
mobile phones obviously there's been a
lot of security talk and less security
development about phones but the
fundamental issue has not changed which
is that we don't approach these types of
devices properly we all have smartphones
but absolutely none of us have
smartphones is no such thing as a
smartphone what you have is a pocket
computer that has an app on it that does
phone service but does voice
communication but actually ninety-nine
percent of the time you're not using it
for that function the reason we call it
a smartphone is that when we had regular
cell phones and smartphones came out the
cell providers wanted you to us right in
if they said well why don't you get rid
of your dumb phone and get a pocket
computer you probably would say no but
if they said any one of you training
your dumb phone for a smartphone that
sounds very very nice but in actuality
these are not phones the full-blown
computers and they need for mon security
and they need the attitude of home loan
facility and we just don't approach that
as a society even though these computers
are actually far more risky than
desktops were 20 years ago or even 15
years ago and those machines we had
antivirus or we had all sorts of earlier
versions of security software for but we
just don't think of these things in our
pockets in the framework that we do and
i should say the people on this call may
but the general society does not so
we're talking about permanently network
connected devices with lots of sensitive
data that are communicating over
insecure protocols to how the second
stitches in orderly reversion to
bluetooth and yet people don't treat
them with the sophistication that they
need privacy is another area with our
major trends in fact as we're talking
now there's discussions in your about
changing legislation that make it much
stricter the age of consent on websites
may go from 13 to 16 exception but the
point is you're going to see major
trends because everybody's tracking
everything all the time and that leads
to privacy violations and there's a
trend on both sides of the Atlantic
towards improving the
security must a privacy for individuals
you can see this trend you're going to
see Louis probably pop out in Europe and
the US and the rest of the world but
you're going to see this for sure in
2015 and we may even see changes yet
remember 15 authentication attached to
something that has gone on for a long
time and will continue to go on for a
long time but I want to talk about a
little bit how we got here and what
forms of authentication we've been using
so we can observe a trend that's going
on right now obviously passwords are an
old form of authentication we will use
only to use them too much inside
passwords have been used successfully
for thousands of years before the
computer age now we know they're
insufficient and we've had government
politics point down so why are they
feeling now well if you think about the
early years of human society passwords
often were used in life and death
situations and night shows up but the
castle presents the password to get in
if a person doesn't get in there likely
to be killed you're not going to forget
password if your life depends on it
you're going to practice it memorize it
know it that you can say it even in your
sleep furthermore you probably didn't
have many passwords like that even 20
years ago how many passwords is a
typical person half maybe they had a
home alarm a student school man had a
locker combination but not very much
more than that and so before the
commercialization on the Internet in the
mid-90s I probably had a very very small
number of passwords maybe those of us
who use bulletin boards before and elec
had a few but with a very very small
number compared to today and so even
complex passwords to be committed to
memory you also didn't have many chances
to get it right that night as that
castle is not going to be able to reset
or say they forgot it or push the button
to have it we sent by email or anything
like that they got to get it right the
first time there was also very little
risk of interception when you went to
your locker and put in the code on your
combination lock you knew it was your
combination lock down device transmitted
message somebody else same with your
home alarm that's not necessary to of
the internet today where you have the
possibility that this could be
intercepted along the way and even when
you have two parties that need to
present password if it would have what
we used to see and will display movie
some sort of secret handshake to
indicate that they should be trusted to
each other in the life
you had mechanisms that work because the
word that many that he had to know in
the computer here with us ways too many
passwords
users in many cases don't care about
some of those passwords you've got
websites that have absolutely no
significant security value to anybody
other than the site itself so for
example sites where you read articles
but you have an account that you have to
log in so unless you're making comments
and stuff for your editing stuff it
really makes no difference to you
whether your time premised on that yet
they're still asking you in many cases
to make these fancy passwords and that
obviously undermines the whole concert
the passwords on this call I probably
don't need to explain too many people
why this wallet sized password list
keeping you know written down passwords
is a problem but yes there are templates
like this online even in 2015 and you
know the descriptions that you can see
here I said you know use this so you can
remember them because they're too hot so
there's been approaches that the first
friend restore these really long and
contorted passwords of special
characters and uppercase research and I
wrote a piece about this for Forbes list
your research shows that this does not
work very well I specialist get too long
people or key characters we know that
statistically when you require upper
lower end special almost always the
uppers and the first character than the
lower than special or the number there's
a lot of things that we can do with
sophisticated analysis that make these
passwords a lot weaker than they are in
theory
is one of the problems that also happens
people can't remember their Lake book
posters I personally like long passwords
when they're created out of multiple
words with number separating them the
word simply learned 7-fiver for
chocolate is a pretty strong password
and is easier to remember at least for
me than the password that appeared on
that post-it note but in any case the
industry trended toward stronger
authentication first concept was
challenged questions I consider
challenged persons to be a move in the
wrong direction to meet challenge
questions I've been writing about them
for years aren't there simply read
preference instead of asking you for a
random password I'm asking you for a
password and telling the world that for
example what color's your first car but
the answer is going to be a color and
it's going to be a color that's used for
cars I you know eliminating nearly all
possibilities for what compassion could
be and I also know that the chances are
pretty good for example in the united
states that if you have large database
anywhere have the color red against the
database you're going to have hit so
instead of having a random password now
i have an incredibly weak password so i
never liked challenge questions and in
the other social media they've become
almost worthless and in fact hurt
security because we train people answer
questions when it shouldn't be answering
the questions if i walked up to you and
said what's your mother's maiden name
you probably would not answer me if i
didn't know you forget websites do this
all the time and in many cases you can
find this on social media several years
ago in American Express for example SP
for their mother's birth date as a
challenge question they no longer do
this near social media that would not
work and if they did stop it before
social media became popular like you
know someone puts on social media
selling my mom's birthday that's not
going to work I'm anyone could find it
if it's publicly readable but think
about mother's maiden name if you go
through someone's facebook friends
most common last name is probably their
own second most common last name of the
thread if they're certainly they have a
group called family or they're talking
about a family event that's probably the
most their name because it's probably
cousins on that side so these are very
very weak issues in the Earth's social
media strong authentication we've seen
all sorts of tokens and biometrics these
work really well inside of an office the
problem is that when these things get
transmitted across the internet you have
the problem of interception if you're
fun plaintes intercepted you can't reset
it so you know there's tremendous risk
if I'd ever need to be used again and of
course the person's doing into something
probably going to try using for all
sorts of nefarious purposes so there are
risks related to these things but in
some station if they do present
advantages one of the other areas
besides the user authentication we
almost never think about this because we
type in URL to let me go there and we
don't think about the fact that site
could be fake but obviously there is
spear fishing fishing that go on you
know those works on the call may check
that the ssl certificates valid or maybe
identity cues or something will decide
on the site to tell if it's legit but
whatever the case may be the best jority
if people certainly do not do a good job
verifying whether it's a side you can
email whomever that's communicating with
them that the party is legitimate and in
fact this brings us to another human
lesson related to pitching is just that
for some reason people trusting that are
in writing to be true it's the same
reason why ridiculous facts particle
effects to me posted on social media and
people will believe them and spread them
without verifying it there in writing
there by a computer when a computer
presents you an email that says pie
apple stuff
people commit a certain greater value
than if someone just walked up to them
on the street and they also think that's
the computer telling them if I send you
an email and you get an email for me
does that mean that it's really for me
or is it your computer telling you that
it's for me it's not really from me it's
passed through many many systems along
the way so it's enough it's digitally
sign it has some proof that it's for me
you need to have some sort of skepticism
especially if it's saying something
strange such as the email in front of
you right now unfortunately we've seen
some poor approaches to this many of us
are familiar with for example pictures
that were put on websites but we're
supposed to prove the authenticity of
the slightly in some cases actually
asked you challenge questions before
presenting pictures which conditions
people to do the wrong thing but there
are all sorts of ways around this those
are starting to disappear but no read if
you would like you can go to my website
and find a way if I wrote in 2006 why
this doesn't work but the point is that
bad approaches are often taken to
authentication issues and they get
deployed and the problems are made and
that's why we're still dealing with
fishing for example more than a decade
after people thought the problem with go
away
there are systems that train people to
recognize phishing emails are cues that
can be put on sites to prevent fishing
and alike but dark the trend is away
from some of these technologies that
don't work the trend is away from
challenge questions and other things
that don't work and make things worse
and of course I should mention it
typically people being fished on going
to be in a state of panic for the state
of concern because there's something
urgent in the email so for example of
message from a CISO a spear phishing
email impersonating a CISO telling
somebody hey I needed to reset a certain
password for system please call me if
you don't get me and you know you try me
two thousand little denius because I'm
on a flight I suggest do it anyway this
one time and of course the person
sending that phishing email on social
media that that seat is so imposing if
they're getting on a flight very
effective spear phishing email and the
person is in a panic because they were
put to cso in the Santa so it says it's
urgent to do something another many
other examples of a similar nature
distributed denial-of-service attacks
continue to be an issue I wrote a piece
recently abandoned about some of the
technological changes that are occurring
with lace relation to them and the
attackers and the mechanisms that
they're using for it but these remain a
problem because taking down the site has
all sorts of recent activists try to
take down site the face don't were taken
down a competing business may want to
start to be taken down if you're not
circulus and certainly foreign
governments at times have reasons to
take down side people who are attacking
Isis related accounts for better for
worse those things are being taken down
sometimes we wonder you know that really
helps because the government might be
monitoring those accounts in that new
accounts and government does know about
to be fed up but whatever the case may
be these have distributed pal service
attacks almost always involved f
deployments of malware so that they can
create Dombey machines around the world
to perform these attacks if people would
not fall prey for things that come L
want for their machines should be the
health service especially a lot more
complicated and difficult to execute
data leakage has been a real problem
over the last few years sometimes it's
through a hacker going in and taking the
data and we mentioned earlier that data
can be more valuable than money at times
and sometimes been result of employee
errors and the employers we get directly
and sometimes it's intentional such as
Lee and it's known ended badly many
cases but the point here is that data
leakage can be catastrophic for a
business and for someone's career that
you think about so need with people who
have to resign and lost a job if you
think about the target breach a similar
story high ranking people but I believe
as a result of you know packs that were
successful and data leaking and data
being stolen and I'm considering all of
those related and the point here is that
you really need to protect your data as
if it's worth more than money because it
probably is and as I mentioned earlier
funding now that's data starting to leak
on social media not by people sending
our spreadsheets but by people saying
things that then helps foremost execute
attacks
you
what's interesting here is that there
are so many errors that are made when it
comes to many of these types of
researchers any which of it any one of
which could have potentially made a
situation much better you know it's a
thing about the government and WikiLeaks
you know you're talking about Edward
Snowden having access to large amounts
of information that he may not
necessarily have needed to have access
to do his job in the case of Manning
you've had a private in the United
States Army who had access to all sorts
of unencrypted diplomatic cables highly
questionable why he needed access to
those from his job the reality is that
many times when there are masses data
leaks us we find out after the fact that
certain principles of information
security weren't applied people had
access to data they shouldn't have stuff
was stored unencrypted and the like and
the point is you need a layered defense
and that's the same thing when it comes
to advanced persistent X we can't rely
on the fact today that that SuperDuper
firewall and perimeter defense
mechanisms and intrusion detection that
you've got an external DMZ and
everything I'm going to defend against
them you think
if someone is especially in the case of
an advanced persistent decker you may
have someone who makes it in and you
need to assume that so you need all
sorts of technology to address that type
of risk and contain the damage there may
be some damage but you want to contain
it you could also have technology for
example that looks for anomalous stuff
going on on the network in the case it's
only a huge amounts of data being
transmitted out to a system that
shouldn't be transmitted out too so
maybe you're detecting hey all the Sun
is this large volume I need to act and
the like so their loss prevention
anomaly detection social media scanning
for things that shouldn't have ever made
it out the door all these types of
things can give you a better picture of
what's going on and contain the defense
and obviously impertinence you know
giving people only what they need access
to the cloud is obviously here to stay
and there are cloud attacks that were
going on several years ago but we're not
done with this problem and part of it is
that people don't always realize how
much valuable data sits out there a
business as many large businesses do and
then also to deals with these providers
for security in the life but the reality
is that you know we are getting that
third-party entities things to watch
that are incredibly valuable to us and
we probably wouldn't give them some of
these things we didn't understand the
consequences the obvious examples of an
individual level is all the new pictures
at leith of celebrities last year where
stuff had been synced up to the cloud
and then the day is stolen from the
cloud potentially or you know other
examples were that's been happening and
again it made the reef passwords on the
part of celebrity but that's irrelevant
the point is that data lived in the
cloud sometimes even after was deleted
on local chain or local devices people
don't necessarily realize what they're
sending out to the cloud that creates
all sorts of risk and of course one of
the things to keep in mind is if there
is a breach if you're simply an
individual or a small business are you
really going to be the first priority of
that vendor who's dealing with big
company data leaking is dealing with
potential clip you know shut down in
their business potentially who knows
what can happen plus they need to
understand it and the third party
richest is another major aspect of a
train that's going on because our
infrastructure doesn't rely on a single
party anymore we have internal
appliances that may come from third
parties we're using third-party
processing services were using
third-party accounting services when
using third-party communication services
in the like a breach at a third party or
a failure at a third party could
directly impact our own information
security right it was believed that
target was breached because something
went wrong at an air conditioning repair
contractor from you know from the earth
from their information security
perspective we had a case recently where
the experience where it wasn't the fault
of the provider that had their to go out
but it was a fault of a customer or of a
third-party associated with them that
they ended up leaking and you can read
articles about this in the media
regularly so understanding and ensuring
that their third parties that you're
doing business with have proper
information security has become
absolutely critical sometimes this is
through agreements sometimes it actually
needs to be done through artists and
other times it's helping them with
information security because the
investment is well worth it for yourself
a one other important concept is a big
brand does not equal great security it
could but it's not always the case many
times a part you need a certain type of
information security product and they
have some specific needs and they say
listen to big brand you know means most
of it no one's fine big brand but the
reality is that their needs are filling
their fires it would be better met my
small company but their worries that
external company is small preferred
vendor list or what's going to happen
with them but you need to understand
that as part of that risk criminals
don't care what brand you buy this isn't
like buying computers where if you buy
the brand name it may cost more but
they'll work the same this is a case
where if you don't address the risk
criminal is going to at some point
probably exploit that risk I'm so that's
the end of the slides if anybody has
questions I'm going to take them in a
moment but you can also contact me on
twitter if you want to discuss this
presentation that's my twitter handle
and you can ask you questions about this
or i'm happy to talk about security and
i do post security or articles pretty
much every day interesting thanks paper
for myself or other writers
free to follow and you'll see some
interesting thing again I want to remind
everybody that for people watching the
webinar the sponsor has given us a fifty
percent off coupon for training courses
in security this is not a discount that
they normally offer as I said you'll see
ten and twenty percent from time to time
fifty percent is a great deal if you're
thinking of saving the cissp exam for
example or other event you know take a
look at the courses this is probably
going to be the time where you'll get
the greatest deal this holiday season
and I paste this code is going to be
valid for another week or so you know
not not going to be laughing
indefinitely so i would take a look soon
and with that all open the floor up the
question so thank you very much okay
there's one question which is from win
it and I'm just pasting that question on
the chat box can you see that the
question that was posed is kick an
end-to-end encryption videos or to all
security questions and the answer is I
know Antonin encryption is a nice thing
for certain forms of communication but
it doesn't solve many issues if an
organization is breached for example
someone on the inside hacker on the
inside could be leveraging those same
communication channels and do a lot of
damage they may get the data after it's
ultimately be tripped and remember to
utilize data you ultimately need to
decrypt it but the exception of things
when you're comparing encrypted string
so if I'm you know gotta ante and
communications for some sort of commerce
at some point I needed decrypted and
process it if there's a criminal in
those systems they have access to it if
there's criminals in memory where the
encryption becomes you're taking place
they could cause problems and of course
none of that is going to address many of
the risk of information leakage there's
certain data to buy last remain
confidential there's certain data that
may have problems that may be leaked in
fashions that has nothing to do with the
primary channel a person for example and
social media may make a post and talk
about you know and a customer they have
may talk about a financial account may
talk about medical stuff and they
violate a law they stalk them out of
attention you know potential merger who
knows what could have you as long as the
people in the process that remains an
issue as well and you know the reality
is an important part of the information
security process but no one technology
no one approached no one technique
addresses all risks Joseph there's
another three questions which is
spending on the chat I've just copied
and pasted ok I'm just looking at them I
there was one question about the
WikiLeaks incident so I'm not going to
go into the whole story that happened
there but you did have an American
soldier who least information that he
had access to at the time and if one of
the questions that came up is why an
American soldier had access for example
to diplomatic cables or diplomatic
cables transmissions between United
States diplomats that were unencrypted
and available to this particular party
one of the things that we should mention
is that there's always this back in for
component and push between the idea of
information sharing and information
security so after 911 there was a major
effort head States to make sure that the
government facilitated information
sharing between different groups so if
there was a security threat that the
Navy heard about the army needs to know
about it soon it's the FBI discovered
something people in the military would
have access to it if the diplomats
discovered something potentially the
right people would need to have it in
the CIA but they may have gone overboard
or they may never have actually had a
better system to begin with and maybe
they were always sharing too much of
this kind of stuff but the point is that
you had people who had access to
information that was highly sensitive
who probably had no business having
access to it so when a private in the
military can get unencrypted diplomatic
cables you run a risk remember the more
people you have the greater risk you
have that one of them may turn out to be
rope or may turn out to have some sort
of psychological issue or what have you
that may lead to something going wrong
so if all the sudden you know you have a
million people having access to
something sensitive the risk of it
leaking or something happening to it are
much greater than if you had you know 10
people having access to it it's not just
who is also just the sheer statistics
and probability so the importance of
making sure people affected everything
that they
in order to do their jobs but not giving
them access to sensitive things that
they don't need to was spied elated by
those particular incident and at other
incidents that we've seen as well
on somebody had asked about IBM in the
operating systems i mention i DN because
in the United States was saying in the
old days that nobody got fired for
buying IBM meaning even if IBM servers
and computer equipment cost more money
than some other vendors especially in
the early eras of personal computers
when you had what they called clones I
in that area it may have talked to us to
buy something else but nobody got fired
for buying IBM at spending a little bit
more money because you were retaining a
certain known quality whereas if you had
bought a no-name brand that the top
again and something went wrong someone
would ask well why didn't you buy the
IBM machine and the point there was that
yes there's a time where people may want
to buy a brand or buy a better quality
as long as both work but when it comes
to information security technology you
got to make sure you have a technology
that actually solves a problem that you
have once you've done a risk assessment
and the like and you know you know what
countermeasures are available what you
need to do I just saying I'm going to
buy the thing that everybody else bought
because my problem is similar to what I
think everybody else's problem is even
though I don't know for sure that's not
a good approach you need to make sure
that you actually threshold risks if
you're worried about and criminals will
find the way to exploit the fact that if
you know you address the eighty percent
of the risks that you have you know
those 20 are then the ones that they're
going to get you on it's not a case of
or 90 91 you get properly the same
concept it's not a case of a checklist
of brand it's a matter of addressing all
the necessary risks what is the best way
to secure from Red somewhere I'm so that
is a great question there are a couple
things that I advise people to do first
of all when it comes to ransomware on
computers if you back up frequently and
you keep those backups just connected
from the computer then even if I machine
got ransomware and someone said I'm
going to steal your data you could take
that data that's backed up and use it on
another machine you really don't have
the same kind of risk that you would if
you don't have another copy of the data
do not keep the backup connected to the
machine because it's the back of this
connection to the machine it could also
potentially get infected or you know the
ransomware name from stuff in the back
up to its
being on the drive or what have you so
you know keep it separated that's number
one number two ransom letter is
delivered as malware rensselaer comes on
because somebody made a mistake they
click something that they shouldn't they
did something they went through websites
that offer you know free movies and the
life that you know some pirated movies
what what have you don't do that if
people don't do that and they stick good
information security practices the
options are going to get malware go down
so that proactive and try to prevent a
malware but have a defensive even if
Mallory did get onto your machine you're
not going to lose it when they can lose
your data because you have another
machine can switch the computer paper
clean to clean the computer or other
lights deal with it
on the other thing to think about is
that when it comes to malware that we
will have these more advanced forms of
malware down the line that could be
serious risks as I mentioned with pars
or medical devices there's really very
little at this point that an individual
can do about those things other than you
know ask when you buy something like
that manufacturers is there something
being done to make sure that this device
is secure so in those types of cases you
may want to ask they're having
vulnerabilities found in these types of
things typically when they hit the media
you're going to be quickly fixed right
to cheeping went to a big discussion in
the media and the life so hopefully over
time those things will be addressed
because of the significant risk to it
but I would expect that eventually we're
going to see some sort of security
technology to address those in the
Internet of Things in smart devices as
well
and can we implement DKIM to avoid
spooking or email also the answer is if
there are technologies that help protect
against phishing domainkeys and elijah
and all sorts of other forms of
technology to authenticate email the
question is those do they work for
individuals who are using it to the work
for the people and there's been all
sorts of complexities in terms of
getting people to actually use this
people are using handles to send email
to going home and sending email if you
can really do that and that typically
will work more in a closed organization
that would work great and you know in
that case at least you would know if the
ciso sent you an email that it really
came from the ciso but remember that
social engineering takes other forms to
it with text message can come in person
could say hey I you know I lost my phone
so I'm sending it from my wife's phone
or what have you on a trip I'm about to
get on the plane you really can't rely
on the technology to address human risks
you really need to adjust the human
wrist also by training the people and
having technology warn them when they're
doing something wrong because just
relying on technology that will
technologically you know block things is
you know are technologically so I think
that in the end of this perspective to
interpret that it doesn't always work
perfectly because you can't guarantee
that a hundred percent of attacks will
always utilize mechanisms that would be
checked by the technology
that's a last question I will
take this question here how are the
tools in the infosec space keeping up
with the growth of all of those threats
that we've discussed to that great
question so there are constantly new
products that come out up there are
constantly new versions of products I
mentioned for example be the best
persistent threats in the last few years
we've seen a whole slew of products that
look for anomalous behavior on internal
networks to a much greater extent than
we've had in the past and that's because
people are worried that they even if I
defend the perimeter someones whose
persistent may get inside and once
they're inside I don't want the whole
you know everything to go wrong I want
to be able to detect it there's
something strange that all of a sudden
you know the CFO's machine is sending
out all the spreadsheets on the drive
you know all over the world and I want
to block that so you know you've got all
these things that will detect anomalous
that then it's per minute obviously I'm
in the space dealing with social media
data leaks that wasn't a problem a few
years ago no it's a sophistical we have
more and more younger people entering
the workforce to use social media a lot
more so we've got a lot more people who
are used to over chittering and we've
got businesses spending more time on
social media because younger generation
now is money to spend and they want to
get that money I get them to buy stuff
so no risk that's created so we've
entered that space you have companies
have entered efficient space to help
train people because there's been this
concept that you know Hades pictures on
the website isn't fully doing the job
you've got a technology I was involved
with creating that using psychologically
sound cues on site that works better
than pictures and hopefully reduces the
number of people that you know create
mistakes you know make mistakes and fall
prey to scam those called green armor
and you can still find that I'm and
that's indecent many banks now and
health care companies so you know you'll
find different technologies that get
created and you know put out there to
address things but in the end it's a
constantly evolving world risks are
detected and technologies domestic
knowledge is the mouth and people are
trying to get around and from a criminal
perspective but in general humans are
still going to be an important facet of
information security and you
can't upgrade the human brain you can
train people you can condition people
but you still need to deal with the fact
that humans do make errors and so you
need technology that's going to address
that unfortunately we're out of time but
I'm going to be giving a series of
webinars talking about other information
security topics perhaps drilling down
more in detail on some of the concepts
and we spoke about today so you know go
and you can check my twitter feed i
always announce them on that speed and
simply learn website and again go look
at the site now if you're looking at for
any courses because this discount that
they providing a fifty percent is
something that's not going to last and i
would take advantage of that if you're
looking for course so thank you
everybody have a great day joseph sorry
to interrupt your partisans if you do
have any questions i would kindly
request you to login to simply learn
forum and you can post your question
there and one over trainer or the
expertise or our speaker will answer
your questions within 24 to 48 hours oh
right because due to the time
consumption we will not be able to cover
up all the questions so it kindly
requests each and every participant to
get into the simply learn forum it's
open forum and request you all to post
your questions thread and our expertise
or the trainer or the speakers will
answer your questions within 24 hours
alright so thank you so much
participants and thank you joseph thank
you so much and is there it is there
anything else that you like to share
with the participants i was going to say
thank you everybody for listening in
today there'll be more webinars your
final month since we don't try to find
them on my twitter feed and i hope we'll
speak again soon in your future so the
webinar will be ending another minute
the web now get ended alright thank you
so much participants